that's I think one of the reasons that
your show has been so successful is it's
a it's a combination of authenticity
with you can have you're totally willing
to have conversations with
no-holds-barred right you can't have
that in the Academy so people need to go
to you to hear these thoughts and to
wrestle with ideas and to engage it's
just it you can't really do it anywhere
else other than a podcast well you can't
do it in the Academy but you can't even
do it on the Today Show they fired
making kefir right what asking why is
blackface racist right which is a stupid
[ __ ] question no doubt and she's not
a bright woman in that regard socially
right so a very clumsy clunky thing to
say they just fire a fire no I shouldn't
what they should have done was brought
in black scholars and black
intellectuals for a week just exactly
Grill exactly and that would have been
amazing television but that attitude
that you have is not what they have so
they want to punish the transgression
right today I think they just want to
stop hemorrhaging and I think they
didn't like her anyway I mean those were
the word is they really didn't enjoy her
and that she wasn't a nice person and
choose a mean it was a learning moment
right it was a teaching moment that's
lost now yes yes but think about in
terms what we were talking about earlier
where the the scholarships stretching
back again to the 60s you have this idea
that all of society is constructed out
of power dynamics that are mediated
through language media imagery and so
she just now became problematic and she
put out ideas that would be dangerous
and poisonous not something to discuss
the merits or dis merits of not
something to work through not something
as a teachable moment she put out an
idea that's dangerous she can't put out
ideas anymore well you know it was
really interesting to she tried she was
so disingenuous and how she approached
is so obvious you know what a black
person is it why is it wrong for a black
person dressed as a white person it's
not no one ever said that why are you
pretending you're just setting it up so
that you could say a white person
wearing black made blackface they think
about they don't think about the other
cultural moment there too so like you
said they bring in blacks
and Athena that she said you know I
really listen to that and yeah
I didn't know that and I was wrong and
I'm changing my mind there was like
woman on Twitter that said her video
look i retweeted it that it looked like
a hostage video yeah yeah I think that
was missing was her holding up a
newspaper that showed the day saw that
yeah oh thanks so [ __ ] funny but that
is one of the worst ways to really
dissect ideas because first of all
there's a studio audience that that
[ __ ] everything up second of all you
have these massive time constraints and
then you have advertisers then you have
a bunch of executives that are all
cowards they're all just ready to pull
the trigger on anything yeah any time
they can blame you for anything that
went wrong and get rid of you or fire
you fire fire him get rid of them
get rid of them bring you the next
person you know and then what they'll
most likely do is to show they've
learned they'll hire an all-black crew
right for the diverse crew that's all
they do matter of fact I think I've read
isn't aren't they doing that see see if
they do that they were placing megan
kelly with a crew of of color think
about where that works right it works
you said they're cowards they're afraid
they're gonna you know damage their
brand or whatever it is yeah where does
that work or who works on that bully's
right so these people why are they so
pervasive in the Academy why are they so
pervasive in media they know they can
bully these people they know that they
can go lean on this stuff and somebody's
going to be cowardly and then they're
gonna be able to you know make something
change in the direction they want it to
change
you see even creeping into politics they
try to do it with policymakers you see
it a lot more in a lot of other
countries right now we're in this
massive like backlash against it in
American politics how's that going you
know to do the 2016 help your
progressive agenda gang a holy crap well
that is a part of the problem with the
what are they saying
so yeah look at this today as you know
we're starting a new chapter in the
third hour of our show as it evolves
it's evolving it's a [ __ ] living
being we want you know the entire today
family will continue to bring you
informative and important stories just
we always have and look two black eyes
and a brown chick that's a hundred
percent diverse princess all diverse
that's the thing is the way that a
diversity is defined if you had a panel
it was just black guys it would be a
hundred percent diverse yes so they've
redefined the word diversity they've
need to find the word inclusion